the Middle East and North Africa a  popular winter Sun destinations and most  visits of trouble free countries  including Morocco Jordan and the United  Arab Emirates so largely considered to  be safe but there are warnings for other  countries Egypt's eastern flank has  considered safe but the Foreign Office  warns against travel to North Sinai  where an is affiliated group called  Sinai province is active sharm el-sheikh  is the only part of the Sinai Peninsula  deemed safe the government in Tunisia  says Libya as a source of security  threats and since the terrorist attack  near seuss in June the foreign officers  advised against all but essential travel  to tunisia turkey too is considered to  be largely safe but there is a threat  from groups including the al-nusrah  front is and the Kurdish PKK that  happened bombings in Ankara and near the  Syrian border and the Foreign Office  advises against travel to that area